[Music]
and I'm going to make the code available
on github ask the toolkit and the link
to the repo is there at the top and the
code is available there and that you
don't really need it to the talkative
and even have to download a couple of
quite large files if you were trying to
make this and they're running their own
folks obsession with the kind of
pointless but it'll be their Street
Hospital you're going to need three CMB
maps and from the planet experiment one
for grammar and lines and power section
we're going to get a bit more detail
later and so welcome to and they're
going to save to date an artist in
cosmology I'm going to provide an
introduction to data analysis and so
where shall I get this give you some
examples of evening bake you can send
one I'm cycle boxes and then we're going
to discuss some of the routines and
notes and libraries bit more detail I'm
going to use specifically for Sandy
so perfect I want Annie with anyone let
me to speak louder and I know Ana
follicle modest and currently I'm
assignment and ml engineer a target and
so cosmology is something I did quite a
few years ago now I've finished my PhD
in 2013 and so recently I started
looking at some of these data set pieces
Python packages which have have been
developed over the last years and
actually give you a really easy way to
start looking at this patient so I'm
going to start with an introduction to
the Fourier transform and just briefly
and because it's a really important
technique in signal processing and
cosmology and many other fields and then
cosmology is used to calculate the power
spectra of signals and by that I mean
we're looking at how power is
distributed into different frequency
components for the signal and by using
free transform we're going to be able to
make some complicated problems easier by
transforming to seriously and I'm going
to go back in a bit more people leave
so what's the ferric transforming kind
of for light and any continuous complex
function can be written on Infante on
males infinity 2020 can be written as an
internet for Plainfield and so we can
write any continuous function as its
climbers cosine and sine and it's that
if you haven't done for a trance once
before that's all we're going to need to
this talk we're going to look at how to
break down signals into frequency
components so this is all you need to
think about is the way that you break
down a signal into some of triggermen
trigonometric functions however in
experimental situations we don't have
continuous functions and we so we've got
finite intervals and with with sampling
and a discreet location so in this case
we use something called the discrete
Fourier transform and if you take a
simple signal and a simple sine wave and
you sample it 10 times you're going to
get a back set Y naught Y sandwich
endpoint and and that sampling is taking
place over a period L of that signal and
and you're going to be sampling that
signal at intervals of delta T so you're
going to have a number of signals in in
and
function which can be broken down into
components like this and if you've got a
wave am signal of twice the frequency
you're going to see something like the
right-hand plot which is the same
starting rate you've still got 30 20
sample content and but that you've got
twice the frequency so you can see that
if you wanted to reproduce that signal
from those 10th from those 20 points and
you would then reproduce the signal
which is 2 times the frequency so the
discrete Fourier transform is an
equation that tells us how to break down
a signal into treatment and please cut
me any question asked question
and and so that formula to discrete
Fourier transform is the sum over the
length of that vector so we've got n
thumps and samples and so we've got Y N
and then we modify both and see factor e
to the minus T PI P n over N and that
gives us you don't need to worry about
this too much what we're doing is
breaking down the signal into and vector
we're transforming from and we also
we're transferring transforming a vector
of n complex members yn into another
vector of complex numbers like a and so
we're starting with a vector in real
space and we're transforming it to the
vector in frequency space YK and I'm
going to show you how to do this using
and the FFT Park library so use the
inverse discrete Fourier transform
because what it says it takes the
inverse transform from frequency space
back to real space so we go from the
vector Y K and frequency wave back to
real space and back to the vector Y n
now this is actually implemented through
an algorithm called the fast Fourier
transform and because the discrete
Fourier transform would be made Leonore
dens were calculations but the closed
very transform takes advantage of the
repeated calculations that you're doing
to speed up and you've got an order n
log n translation and this is like the
EM algorithm that system
in FFT libraries if you wanted to do
some reading about the original
algorithm and I'm going to put this link
in with the code that you can you can
download the speed later and all of
these literally available now let's look
at one example of practically how to
calculate spirit transform of and a
signal so what I've done here so this is
a bit small on the top you can see three
different arranged on the left hand side
we've got one point on here on the top
left so this is the top row is then is
an array of just ones and zeros so what
we've done is place of one at position
zero five in that array the difference
up top is frequency space and we've
taken the inverse Fourier transform to
go from frequency face to real space
which is on the bottom so the free
transform of that inverse Fourier
transform of this graph gives us and
this close here
we can see that we're getting what we
expect which is sine function and it's
oriented depending on where you place
that point and frequency of these you
can take this library and flavor that
yourself and see for some more
competitive examples what happens I mean
the way I started with looking at the
Pro transformers because the MD analysis
it's really important so I'm going to
show you a graph later on other end of
the CMB power spectrum and we're going
to come back to this theory bit later on
so what's the CMB and it's a uniform and
isotropic field which is released about
300,000 years of big time and I'm and
today we measure it as a temperature of
about about 2.7 to help
so just absolute zero
CMB sorry clear the Cosmic Microwave
Background and so it's this radiation
that was released when so in being they
were in the early stages where you had a
cloud net so at that point electrons and
protons 300,000 years after the Big Bang
electrons protons could we provide and
form neutral hydrogen and up until that
point radiation was coupled with matter
so it couldn't string through the
universe at that point the radiation
decoupled history including the earth
and that these radiation that we're not
measuring and which has been it's being
cooled to 3 Kelvin so we can there have
been a lot of experiments measuring this
radiation and it's a really interesting
problem in data analysis because the
fluctuations in this viewers eye off the
order of 10 to the minus 5 Kelvin and
there's a very low signal to noise ratio
so you can imagine that any any noise
and that signal from the galaxy or from
your instrument that you're measuring
the sky with is going to create noise
that you have to remove that we can
finish we can observe for C and B and in
particular ground-based experiments have
very large arrays of thousands of
detectives on employing large fraction
to the sky
and creating very large time streams and
those time streams need to be processed
and and turned into that to the sky I'm
going to show you now some easy routines
that you can use and pipe in to
visualize this data so this first
example is an example of using the field
high library so if you download this
data set you can use the help I read map
function to read in one of these data
sets which is in the fifth file format
and you can then look at this using the
multi multi function so you can this
plan code to you is just an array so we
can view that a row using this function
and we can set the minimum and maximum
temperatures so if it is really hard to
see it
so we can set the minimum maximum
temperatures and these factors and
mohtadeen Kelvin so that's 300
microkelvin
bottle - dream - microfilming and if we
look at this map you can see a series of
Peaks which are roughly plus and minus
300 micro Kelvin so this is of the order
of 10 to the minus 5 Kelvin to be the
tiny character fluctuations but you can
see some really interesting structure in
this map would be Kelvin which is yeah
that what is that what that 0 will be
always in our business fluctuations
around 2 point 75 degrees and centered
on the temperature of the ambient just
passing - fluctuations of U and
[Music]
okay so a couple more links here for you
to get some big sets and you're going to
find that this data is M and set file
format which is the cosmologists
favorite file and format but big
packages and work with those files
so this remap function reads one
[Music]
okay so I said that that map shows some
interesting structures and we're going
to think about how to describe some of
that structure so as we need to
understand how to describe this random
retort on which is spanning the
celestial sphere so we can think about
this map as just an array and this array
is each one of this is Ray is a sample
of a position on the sphere so if you
think about the sphere in three
dimensions we're looking at and we're
looking at it in different directions
and with measuring a continuous random
field on that sphere so we can and we
measure that using an experiment and we
then sample that field onto a vector
which is this array Y where n is the
number of pixels in and the map
and now the CMB is actually because the
initial post patient's were
approximately galloping in and the CNB
is going to Auto be close to a gallon
right field so this field should have a
Gaussian distribution to your familia
bell curve or the normal distribution so
actually that vector should be random
should be a multivariate and by this
function so let's take a look at that
and see if that's true
so we can just plot that as a histogram
pop your rate and we can also fit a
Gaussian to it with parameters mu and
Sigma and if we do that then to look at
this plant piece that we've looked at we
can see that this feature is very very
close to Gaussian and again we unit
sarah kovin
okay so we've got this data set but now
we want to start doing some cosmology
with it we can now make use of another
Python package which actually we can use
to predict what this field should look
like given some initial conditions and
it's a really useful package called so
if you can imagine that we have a
cosmological model which is described by
a set of parameters and we can then
given that model and we can evolve those
initial conditions and we can then
predict what this and project what the
CMB would look like if you want to have
a look at this package then have a look
at McCann and it's so it's called proto
and I stock trapeze in the microwave
background and it's a Fortran library
which has this MC interface now and in
Python you can pick em store em and then
you can get access to this code and we
can I'm going to show you an example of
how simple it is to use this library so
we can create an effective parameters
and you don't even need to set the
temperature of the standing and I've
just done that that I can use it later
on and one of my thoughts all you need
to do is on that object which stores
your parameters you can call set
cosmology and then give it
I'll explain what L is later on you just
need to set your initial parameters this
is what those parameters looks like and
you can see that using the default
parameters is a lot simpler than going
in and definitely all of these
individually we can do a quick
validation should see that they make
sense and if you want to test your own
personal to cosmological parameters you
can go to this website and change those
parameters and it will produce for you
several outfit files that you can save
and then important to pipe them and then
if you want to use them for your
analysis
so from this library now we can get the
CM something called the CMV power
spectrum and I'm going to explain what
can be percenters okay so I've taken
some data from the planck website just
to have a look at what this power
spectrum is and compare it to the
results of the lot of curve and if we
plot these power spectra if we get
something that looks like this and the
one that i produced using mine probably
may use default parameters is the black
line and the plants best fit data so
this is the vertical parameters which
better apply I think 2015 data is the
red line here and so the differences are
due to the fact that chromatids which
I've sent I'm probably different to the
best approaches from the face set but
they're quite similar and quite nice see
we're going to come back to this later
on and explain in a bit more detail but
on those x-axis here you can see
something called L which is I'm going to
go into what this is now and on my
y-axis is the something with the power
spectrum so we're going to now relate
this back to the free transform and
think about how how L corresponds to
scales and the sky so what we need to
now look at is something called the
sparrows and monix and these are the
first few spiritual harmonic functions
so quite scary looking but if we look
plot them and we're going to I'm going
to put them in in a bit but what we're
going to do is see that we can break
down the temperature into some of these
spherical harmonic functions and this
equation here you can see with we now
have something very similar to the free
transform where we're breaking down a
signal into a sum of odd functions and
we're waiting those functions by an
amplitude which is a and this is you
know analog for decomposition in flat
space so in fact those we have Fourier
transform and in on if you're describing
a field on sphere then you need to use
spherical harmonics and but L in that
equation is related to the angular scale
which like so it relates to how and the
Angela scale of those fluctuations are
you seeing and and M is related to how
those are closed modes are integers
have a look at these functions now and
then come back to this so there's some
code here to plot these functions which
I've taken from an but an unlined bit
and we're going to take a look at these
so the first circle harmonic is just a
constant it doesn't have any angular
dependence so it's just a very boring
constant and if we look at the first one
things start asking interesting and we
can see that the first set of harmonics
have two values at the end and this
first one it's here and second one is
here you can see that M is related to
how these moods are oriented oriented on
the sky and L is related to the angular
scale of those fluctuations so he ran a
loved one is corresponding to
large-scale fluctuations so if we look
out at the universe with looking at
large scale fluctuations 180 degrees
apart as L gets higher we're looking at
smaller angular scales so if we plot the
second one we see those different
marries again different orientations but
we can see that as L increases the
angular scary situation gets smaller
and what we're going to do now is see
how you can use these feral harmonics to
make to create recreate the CMB and
someone has created these lovely
animations which are gonna look
so those circle harmonic functions in
this visualization you can see if we
just wait for it to restart
okay so we're seeing those large-scale
fluctuations and if you add smaller and
smaller and give scales then you add up
those 400 marks with different weighting
and if you add up all sorts of harmonics
and with with weightings that looks like
this function on the top left and you
get something that looks like this
awesome awesome
so this is how you create the Sanvi from
Oracle home Linux
so
so let's think how is L which was on
that plot I showed you earlier related
to data and L of 200 is roughly 1 degree
on the sky and the full moon if you view
for beautiful moon from our past about
past degree to give you an idea so let's
go back to that plot and look at now
here if you look on this look at scales
about one degree which is L of two
country you can see that there's a lot
of power on that angular scale so the
power spectrum here is telling you how
that signal can be broken down into
frequency component and we're just now
weapon on a sphere instead of a 2d plane
okay
so one more thing that we need to know
before we can look at a clip before we
can calculate the power spectra from
some real data is and what one of the
most important instrumental effects that
we need to think about and Fourier
transform is one of the useful
properties is that you can convolved as
a signal where I convolve two functions
and free space under multiplication so
we're going to look at in frequency
space we're going to model what as what
a telescope beam would look like as this
function here which is a Gaussian and
we're going to plot that below so this
on first and beam size of thirds of arc
minutes which is about which is half a
degree if we look at what our telescope
beam would look like it would look
something like this so when we look at
this when we measure the sky with a
telescope what we're actually doing is
observing the CMB through a length which
is therefore a convolution of the sky
with an instrument instrumental beam so
in Fourier space we can multiply those
two functions together take proof in
inverse very transform and and come and
get a smooth version of the sky
okay
so what I'm going to do now is
[Music]
look show you how now how you can now
use some libraries to calculate power
spectrum how much of these data so what
what you can do is you still play
library and what we're going to do is
compare the Sandy with a white noise
array so what I've done is created just
an array of white of white noise of the
same room length and the Planck data and
plotted that so here you can see a white
noise map this is clearly very different
to the math I showed you earlier because
we don't see any structure and if I plot
a histogram of those points as I did
earlier we can see that again we get
something which is a Gaussian
distribution so wearing one that do we
see this structure and in another we
just seen noise when they have the same
distribution this is when we need to go
back to that power specter and think
about the frequencies and make up that
sequence we're going to do that in a bit
in
so we split white noise and we've booked
I've sorted here those purses grams of
those three year out of those three two
data sets now on top of each other just
to show you how similar now now let's go
back to the plant temperature map why do
we have structure in one of these maps
and not in the oven so let's look at
this house sector in more detail so this
prospect I downloaded from the flight
website and I just I've just plotted it
and again this isn't a lot but now for
those think looks to be in different
position but this third peak here is
that peak at 1 degrees on the sky which
is where we see the most power in the
map and if we look at the CNB map you
can see power on that map and on scales
of 1 degree and so this is how you can
think about the transform from first
beta-2 to real state and white noise has
a so this I'm going to notice what the
power spectrum of that white noise array
and compare it with the power spectrum
of the pragma and so we're going to see
the differences in terms of Y and one
each instruction in the other
okay so on this graph here we've used a
function called Anna fast which is in
the Hill High library to go from a white
noise array to a power spectrum so this
is a really easy thing to do in Python
now and you can then scale and tighten
scaling factors and plot this and we're
going to compare it with that with the
theoretical power spectrum which I
downloaded from the website so what I've
done here is I've downloaded three maps
from the plant website and I've taken
the power spectrum I think in the I've
applied this function here and a farce
to those three maps and I'm going to now
plot the results
and you can see that the data gives us
something which is very very close to
the theoretical power spectrum which is
nice
I've had to apply some scaling factors
here and you can look at those in the
code in more detail later and I think
questions if you have any if you're
getting a question about them but what's
interesting is that this great plot here
is gray line is that white movies have
the white noise of that power spectrum
of the white noise earring that I
created earlier and you can see that the
power spectra of white noise is
something which is increasing like K
squared so in white noise we don't have
this lovely peak upscaling without one
degree and that's why we don't see that
structure when we look at white noise
that we do when we see Z and if I plot
that on a log-log plot you can see that
that white noise power spectrum is a
straight line as you this set and the
data touch the so the data to has come
from black 2015 data and the red line I
think is the best fit power spectrum
that dataset so you have to play that
with some of the scaling factors in
order for these two lines to match up
and you can look at that
and I'm going to stop there and see and
visit for the few more interesting
what's that we can look actually got any
more questions and I'm going to stop
there and I am every question so on the
top actresses Debbie gay sir there were
these kind of oscillations but a
frequency that yeah do if there are
directions first event so they're called
and affected populations so that created
those that to understand how how those
are created you need to go look at early
universe Pacific's and think about how
the initial translations which was dated
in the Big Bang how they would have
although the time to use the DMV and
I've been to you as a scientist order I
don't remember that they called Achates
populations um
shortly and well I said just one library
which I didn't talk about which is XML
and which I started looking at and but I
think it's being publicized here as well
and so if this is another library that
you can start doing and machine learning
on date sets and that's a really good
example did I haven't had any time to go
through some of the examples from this
website that I wanted to show including
our most interesting
thank you
[Music]